الجيش الاسرائيلي يواصل تنفيذ عمليات
تفجير وتدمير واسعه لمبان سكنيه ومنازل
ومنشات على طول الشريط الحدودي تحديدا في
المناطق الشماليه والشماليه الشرقيه في
قطاع غزه وهذا عمليا ما كنا نرصده منذ عده
اسابيع لعمليات تفجير لهذه المباني وايضا
حجم الدمار الذي يظهر معنا في الصوره لكل
هذه المناطق الحدود
واليوم اكد ذلك تقرير ورد في صحيفه دعوت
احرونوت الاسرائيليه وقال بان الجيش
الاسرائيلي بدا يستكمل عملياته في تسويه
الاف المباني والمنازل في المناطق
المحاذيه للشريط الحدودي بالارض تحديدا
شمال وشرق قطاع غزه وذكرت الصحيفه ان قوات
الجيش ستواصل هذه العمليات وستقوم بعمليات
تدمير وتفجير مماثله ايضا في المناطق
الجنوبيه تحديدا في منطقه خزاعه بادعاء ان
هذه المباني تشرف على بلدات اسرائيليه
حدوديه في غلاف غزه وقد تشكل تهديدا في
المستقبل بحيث يتم استهداف هذه البلدات
باطلاق صواريخ مضاده للدروع او ان تستهدف
في عمليات قنس الصحيفه نشرت هذا اليوم
صورا من وحده توثيق
تابعه لسلاح الجو الاسرائيلي ووحده
الاستخبارات العسكريه تظهر هذه المناطق ما
قبل الحرب وما بعد الحرب وتظهر عمليا حجم
الدمار الهائل في هذه المناطق المحاذيه
للشريط الحدودي وهي عمليا ربما تظهر ايضا
الخطه الاسرائيليه لهذه المناطق ما بعد
الحرب بانشاء حزام امني وفقا للتسميه
الاسرائ او منطقه عازله بحيث لن يسمح
لسكان هذه المناطق بالعوده اليها كي تبقى
كما تسميها اسرائيل مناطق عازله في
المستقبل نجوان سمري الجزيره من منطقه
غلاف
غزه